welcome to an introduction to drip
irrigation
this key farm element can be part of a
sustainable farm system
that considers conservation of natural
resources farm economic sustainability
and produce safety in the next few
minutes you will hear and see an
overview of drip irrigation
implementation for farm enhancement from
a whole farm planting perspective
installing a drip irrigation system may
lower your cost
and your food safety risks there is also
no doubt
that installing an irrigation system
also protects the farm
income from the financial effects of
drought
drip irrigation also called micro
irrigation or trickle irrigation
provides a slow and steady source of
water
right on or below the soil surface drops
of tiny streams move through emitters
each emitter delivers a metered amount
of water
some drip systems are in line and some
have
detached emitters that can be placed
along the drip lines
the water is distributed by these
emitters and provide a consistent source
of water across the bed by keeping the
foliage free of excess water
you can reduce the spread of plant
disease this system is not the best
choice for crops that require frost or
freeze protection
or cooling which involves overhead
delivery for maximum
effectiveness applying the water
directly to the root zone also reduces
the potential
of water to serve as a vehicle for human
pathogen contamination
to the edible portion of your crop since
it is possible
for soil insects or rodents to enter the
irrigation system
through broken lines carefully inspect
the system
to keep the water supply safe
this system reduces your water uses so
it can also save you money on your
electric
or water bill another advantage is the
ability to apply chemicals through your
irrigation lines
this helps keeps them from spreading on
a windy day and potentially
contaminating a public water source or a
crop
you don't intend to treat carefully
managing fertilizer applications through
drip irrigation and flushing the soil
with water when necessary are important
in a high tunnel
since the building up of salts is
possible with this system
tools like flow meters to automate the
delivery
of precise amounts of water timers and
soil moisture
sensors can help you monitor the use of
your water
safely and efficiently the usda natural
resource conservation service can
provide financial assistance
for implementation of conservation
practices through the environmental
quality incentives program
and the conservation stewardship program
nrcs and extension
can also provide technical expertise to
help
implementing drip irrigation on your
farm drip irrigation is a common way to
conserve water
reduce plant disease reduce food safety
risks
and reduce costs
you